canal is with us canal is in columbus
ohio
hi canal what's up hi how you doing
better than i deserve how can we help
i had a quick question about um self
banking with whole term life insurance
and whether it's worth it if you accrue
a cash balance
and borrow against that and pay interest
to yourself
or if you should stay away from that and
keep using a bank
yeah it's an absolute scam
it's a whole life policy it's not a turn
it's not a term policy
it's a whole life life insurance policy
basically whole life life insurance is
where you pay
20 times more for the same amount of
insurance
and so the extra 95 dollars out of the
hundred dollars goes into a savings
account
and um that you earn very little on
after you finally start to build it up
and then one of the ways they're
pitching it now is the self-banking
concept where you use your own money
which by the way when you have a
checking account you are
using your own money i don't know why
they think that's magical
okay perfect i guess i won't use that no
i i wouldn't use it i would stay
completely away from
the company that is offering it and any
other offerings that they have
because it is a really really bad
product
and it is a scummy way to sell whole
life life insurance which is a scummy
product to start with
but no one sells that stuff anymore
except people no one believes in it or
talks about it positively
except people that are in that business
and this whole thing of you can borrow
your own money why would i want to
borrow my
it doesn't even make any sense dave but
this is the power of marketing
i mean the message here is really look
into stuff i love that people can call
and get advice on this
but really dig into stuff and and and
does it make sense
and if it doesn't make sense why doesn't
it make sense but they put some
wonderful marketing copy on this
yeah so from yourself give you another
one it just keeps
yeah didn't that great and you pay and
you pay them interest
right to borrow money from to borrow
your money that you saved up in your
savings you're moving money from your
checking account to put it over there to
them to not even get a good return on it
to get it back it's just
it's mind numbing it's like moving a
pile of rocks from one side of the yard
to the other
back and forth back and forth back and
forth and so here's the other one
uh whole life life insurance you can uh
you can use it cash value insurance
grows tax-free
well no it doesn't that's a lie but
here's how they
propose that you do this you overpay for
your insurance by
20 times for all of your life your whole
life that's where it comes from they
take your money your whole life
and finally you have some money in there
let's just say you've got 50 000
in there now if
the 50 000 is in excess of
what you paid in and you take it out
that is taxable because there's a gain
right
yes but not if you borrow it
and so you put money into this
investment now you can borrow
your money that you put in there
back out and pay them interest
but it's tax-free yeah well no kidding
doofus when you go to the bank and
borrow 50 000
they don't charge you taxes on it it's a
debt
yeah of course it's not taxable
debt is not taxable yeah but it's not a
tax-free growth on an investment like a
roth ira or roth 401k
it's not even on the same planet yeah
it's the same kind of stuff that he's
dealing with there and it's this whole
idea of but but
boy i mean you talk about i mean they're
they're almost as scummy as the
timeshare people
yeah they're almost that scummy yeah
they're almost as scummy as the payday
lenders they're right up there
that's straight up manipulation what you
just laid out for us as clear as you
could lay it out
that's manipulating people lying yeah we
could call it
dave ramsey is giving bad advice because
with whole life you could get
tax-free growth no you can't
yeah no you can borrow your
own money and pay them
interest right and borrowed money is
always
tax-free because it's borrowed right
it's not an actual investment
so yeah that's how that works but but
i'm the crook
and i'm the one that doesn't know what
he's talking about according to that
industry
now if you want some people pissed off
at you that's a good group of people to
have pissed off at you
the time share people are pissed off at
me yeah the uh
car fleecing people are pissed off at me
the payday lenders hate my guts
and the whole life people oh my god you
would
think i would have you taken on the rent
to own furniture people yet
you know they just don't do much anymore
right okay i'm just trying to think of
anybody else while we're
we should go ahead and get a full list
of the scumber people you don't get
christmas cards from yeah
yeah well i mean rent to own is
actually you know i have they are taking
on in a couple of our books and a couple
of our courses over there yeah
yeah but i don't really hear from them
much yeah it's not a popular moment yeah
the nothing down same as cash furniture
people they're not happy with me
no best buy screwing people with that
stuff for decades
yeah this ain't the best buy people yeah
you know it's not hard to figure out
yeah the product protection plan people
they don't like either
yeah yeah all the extras why is it that
everybody makes you the bad guy because
you're trying to save people money
well i'm just trying to save people
that's the point yeah you're hurting the
big corporate scams
and so that's why they come at you like
everybody didn't already know payday
lenders were a screw job
like like all of america knows time
everybody knows a time share is like the
worst
thing on the planet yeah and like
they're shocked
that dave ramsey said it out loud the
timeshares are scummy
yeah oh my god of course we said it out
loud they were scummy long before i
back when i had a hair they were yeah
well when you offer all these free
things just for a meeting which by the
way
i did it one time you didn't i did you
went in the tiger cage
yeah because the package was so nice and
steady see the tiger for an
hour and you get a free pass to the zoo
for a year so stacey
tiger hasn't eaten in four days but come
in the cage and pet the tiger for an
hour oh here's the deal
i didn't pay attention to my wife this
is a great story yeah she's like you're
gonna have to sit there and listen i'm
like trust me i won't
i'm the guy that goes there's no chance
well i went in just mr stonewall i'm not
gonna do it like you're the only one's
ever done this i know
and then sat there and just got worn out
i tried to be rude i tried to get kicked
out
i'll give the guy credit he made me sit
there for 90 minutes but i'll tell you
what
i got all the stuff too so that was it
it was the last time i
did it it was not worth it it's our
first year of marriage buy your
own hotel room yes buy your own hotel
room it ain't worth it no
don't pet the tiger in the tiger cage
yeah it's good he will eat your butt
yeah you'll come out of there with a 26
000 time share that's worth a dollar
yeah you can't sell it for a dollar on
ebay you can't get out of it
no you is stuck baby you've been petting
a tiger don't go in the tiger cage
no wonder he hadn't eaten in three days
there's nothing as greedy as a time
share salesman
oh my god